quand vous avez été en difficulté
beaucoup de gens du milieu du cinéma
vous en tournez le dos vous qui êtes
hypersensible ça vous a beaucoup affecté
aujourd'hui que vous revenez très
courtisé que vous repartez du bon pied
c'est que vous avez regardé est-ce que
vous les regardez un peu avec un regard
amusé ou ironique en disant à l'époque
vous ne tourniez le dos et maintenant
vous revenez non parce que
[Musique]
ceux qui reviennent et qui m'ont fait du
mal avant
je travaillerai pas avec eux je leur
ferai rappeler en tous les cas hein au
moment où j'ai eu besoin de toi je m'as
pas tendu la main là tu as besoin de moi
je vais pas venir j'ai un ami avec moi
on a trouvé encore comme je me répète un
petit peu on a des gens des chefs
d'entreprise qui mis sur sa Mina série
qui aime la mentalité de Samy Naciri
l'écriture de Bibi Naceri et donc ces
gens-là c'est ce qu'on grandit avec les
taxis la plupart des jeunes mecs de 25
30 ans d'aujourd'hui et qu'avait 8-10
ans ou leur papa et eux aujourd'hui là
on vient de produire Eric vient de
produire on a on a tout produit tout
seul on sait auto-produit on n'a rien
demandé ni CNC ni aide à l'écriture on
aurait pu le faire peut-être même le
redonner mais on voulait pas perdre de
temps et bien tous ces gens sont venus
ils ont mis de l'argent avec nous on a
fait notre film on est en montage je
prépare un seul à se lancer qu'on va
produire nous avec Eric quoi Eric qui
fait qui est producteur
voilà quoi je veux dire
je fais les choses tout seul ceux qui
vont venir et qui n'auront pas fait de
mal dans les acceptera volontiers et
puis ceux qui étaient pas là quand
j'avais besoin d'eux et qui m'ont pas
tendu la main qui m'ont plutôt écrasé
ben on leur dira non désolé vous étiez
pas là quand on avait besoin de vous
continuez votre chemin juste amis tu
disais tu parlais de serrer de tous ces
moments enfin j'ai parlé de ces moments
difficiles est-ce qu'à un moment tu t'es
dit je vais jamais remonter la pente
où est-ce que c'est dur mais il y a
toujours c'était dur mais j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir des potes d'avoir des
amis déjà mais j'ai eu la chance de de
pouvoir avec grâce à Luc Besson grâce à
ce film qui m'a fait connaître dans le
monde entier le taxi il a été vendu dans
le monde entier il a été traduit dans
mais je sais pas combien de langues
alors on est en guerre avec la Russie
l'Ukraine et Tanguière avec la Russie
moi quand j'ai connu la Russie il y a 6
ans mais je suis Brad Pitt en Russie
nous a dit ça donc
aujourd'hui
mais je veux dire par là j'ai eu la
chance que à un moment donné il fallait
s'expatrier et grâce à taxi j'ai pu
aller travailler et continuer à à
s'ouvrir ma passion Natacha oui Samy on
parle souvent en fait des choses qui
nous parasitent le souvenir des gens qui
nous ont fait du mal ou qui nous ont
fait trébucher mais on parle plus
rarement des gens qui nous ont fait du
bien et qui nous ont aidés qui nous ont
soutenus qui nous ont élevés aussi
est-ce que tu as est-ce que cette
reconnaissance maintenant prend plus de
place si tu veux dans ton esprit plutôt
que la partie négative mais ils ont
toujours été là ceux qui m'ont fait du
bien mais toi tu as une vraie
reconnaissance mais moi je suis je suis
quelqu'un de comme ça moi j'aime ou
j'aime pas tu me fais du bien je te fais
du bien tu me fais du mal je vais éviter
de te faire du mal parce que je veux pas
l'emprison où je veux pas faire
d'histoire je vais t'ignorer mais tous
ceux qui m'ont fait du bien aujourd'hui
ils savent que je suis là
oui tu es là pour eux je suis là pour
eux comme ils sont là pour moi j'ai pas
de problème
ça mille est comme ça il aime ou il aime
pas voilà par exemple on va là il y a
plein de gens ici je l'ai fait
[Rires]
sans transition
qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans les couloirs oui qu'est-ce que je
t'ai dit tout à l'heure dans les
couloirs et à part ça que j'étais bien
depuis le début de l'année
qu'est-ce que je t'ai dit dans les
couloirs que j'étais le seul que vous
allez garder j'ai dit ça tout le monde
avant l'émission d'exploit de la
chroniqueur franchement
du succès énorme et mondial de taxi et
des taxis mais il y a un film très
important pour le jeune public c'est
indigène parce qu'on parle aujourd'hui
de du film tirailleurs avec Omar Sy sur
les tirailleurs sénégalais mais je
trouve que indigène vous avez vous êtes
allé à Cannes vous avez été multiprisé
très très important
et je trouve que dans votre film c'est
quand même très important de parler de
ce film pour le jeune public parce que
c'est bien devoir taxi mais c'est bien
aussi de voir ce film là ça c'était une
parenthèse ciné et ensuite juste vous
est-ce que vous avez un regret bien
évidemment mais c'est quoi
la table s'embrouiller avec moi elle a
deux regrets avec moi
mon plus grand regret moi je vais dire
mon plus grand
maître
j'en ai j'en ai beaucoup
qui m'ont fait encore qui vous emmerde
vraiment quoi qui vous dit merde
pourquoi j'ai fait ça ou qu'elle est
énorme c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
d'avoir pas rester dans les clous
ou ou j'aurais dû rester dans les clous
et c'est tout traversé dans les clous et
je me suis dit j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
parce que je suis bon et que les gens
ils me font travailler je faisais quatre
films quatre films par an et puis voilà
quoi et il y a une chose que je voudrais
rajouter par rapport à ce que vous dites
Samy son fils Julian et son frère bibi
j'ai jamais vu ça ces trois personnes
qui s'entraident des fois c'est quand
ils sont chez moi on dirait que c'est
l'explosion Gaza à côté c'est sympa mais
je veux dire mais quand quand par contre
ils essaient de travailler ensemble ils
font des choses ensemble c'est
extraordinaire et ça la famille la série
c'est quand même quelque chose Samy il a
donné cette âme à son frère il a donné
cette âme à son fils et je trouve que
dans la notion des transmissions du de
travail c'est quelque chose de très très
beau et ça fait partie j'allais dire du
succès de famille borsalino tu veux dire
quoi
tendresse pour pour sa vie on en parlait
il y a deux jours sur le fait que les
gens qui étaient en des stars avaient
forcément et quelques déviances et c'est
vrai que on ne sait pas quand on est pas
comme les autres mais ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que tu dis tu fais des Cathy
parents et j'ai des problèmes que j'ai
souvent quand ça dévisse ça dévisse
à savoir
non mais moi je me quand j'ai compris
que ce que les portes se fermaient ça va
extrêmement vite bien sûr est-ce que
c'était pareil pour toi mais sur ça va
super vite
c'est que la mytho c'est que la
mythologie le mytho c'est qu'il est
légendes mais avons une vitesse mais
c'est un truc de fou ah ouais ouais les
rumeurs mais les rumeurs surtout
abusé
et tu te dis mais où ils vont chercher
des trucs pareils donc tu te dis que
[Rires]
les plâtres et de remettre les pendules
à l'heure et c'est ce qu'on va faire
dans dans un peu dans le seul en scène
on n'est pas là pour faire on va pas
faire pleurer dans les chaumières on va
mettre un peu ces on va raconter des
annales des anecdotes émouvantes tristes
et à la fois on va faire rigoler les
gens et on va mettre des barres sur
l'été des points surréis vous avez parlé
de de du match de Gilles Verdez quand il
va arbitrer il y a ma mère
mais Baba en fait c'est quoi son film
donc elle demande c'est quoi ton film il
va arriver maman il va arriver il y a
des films qui arrivent et Sandy en plus
qu'elle connaît bien l'ami Sandy
aussi
ce qu'on vous a pas dit
c'est que Eric encore une fois ici
présent nous a fait n'a été nous
chercher des producteurs américains donc
il a été chercher un producteur de Los
Angeles qui est encore une fois sa Mina
série le travail de Samy Naciri
l'écriture de bibina Cherie puisque la
relève 2 a été écrite mais la série qui
avait été écrit le premier volet il a un
fils de 25 ans il a un fils de 25 ans
qui est mon fils aussi on a un fils
soulevé on est on l'accorde voilà on l'a
conçu tous les deux lui pour l'écriture
et moi pour l'active et donc il
l'écrivent tous les deux donc
Eric nous a vraiment Raymond dans la
montagne
l'autre jour au restaurant qui
conduisait les bagnoles et qu'il aimait
bien les bagnoles quand il était plus
jeune avec ses potes
donc on a écrit une scène pour lui et
son lit puisque sandy est aussi avec
nous parce qu'il fait partie de la
famille et des gens que j'aime comme ils
n'ont jamais lâché donc sandy est avec
nous sur la mentale et depuis le début
et donc ils vont piquer des bagnoles
ensemble dans la mentale 2 puis
appliquer des choses
avec Sandy
et tu crois que c'est Jean Gabin le gars
[Applaudissements]
une nouvelle carrière
ok qu'est-ce que tu veux l'entraîneur
dedans
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le travail
de Samy Nacer sur la gestion du succès
vous avez connu le succès très vite très
haut vous êtes devenu star en France
International c'est quoi la plus grosse
folie que vous avez faite quand vous
avez touché vos premiers gros cachet
j'ai lu Besson m'a permis d'acheter un
appartement
à Boulogne en face du bois que j'ai tout
cassé le temps non merde j'ai fait des
travaux
et ça a été en face du bois la folie
c'est d'acheter mon premier appartement
et c'est bien oui c'est pas une folie
non une fois si c'est une folie pour moi
faisait tous les soirs ça
non j'en ai pas des comme ça c'est
peut-être voyagé partir à l'étranger des
choses comme ça partir avec ma chérie à
l'autre bout du monde au Seychelles j'en
sais rien voyager découvrir le monde
parce que je faisais quatre films par an
et parce que tu gagnais beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque ouais beaucoup ouais
[Applaudissements]